welcome to the recruitment rollercoaster
podcast my name is Hisham Aziz and we're
in bright and early again I'm joined by
a Nick guy and who works for Finney
James and is currently you currently
head up the American side of Finney
James yeah so Nick has actually traveled
all the way from San Francisco to do
this podcast especially Nick has as I
was just saying we're always always like
to start and how the hell did you get
into recruitment mate how did that
happen
probably the same story as everyone else
maybe you never heard of it and then the
next minute you're in it yeah kind of
out of university needed a job knew
someone who'd done recruitment and a lot
of money and then yeah before I knew I
couldn't live this was what some of your
mates do not make so one of my kind of
parents friends like next-door neighbor
actually when I would I grew up he'd
about four or five years older than me
he's kind of gone into referral so
happens immensely actually speech with
neighbors then he'd gone into it and I
didn't know anything about it still but
heard he was successful was there see
like the car is driving and all that or
he was live in London so he can drive he
was he'd gone down yeah they were
speaking highly of him and exactly okay
what did you do before then because I
think I saw in your LinkedIn you worked
at Manchester for a bit yeah where's the
money nights in like hospitality I
really whilst I was at uni re-watch is
it you know so yeah I came straight on
University from the James really that's
that's interesting and then solo I think
what I really want to dive into with you
is that obviously so you're sort of just
to set the scene that you've obviously
how long you work for finish ends now
like fire just come up to six years so
tell me now it's been your only
recruitment job right it's been my only
real job a real job yeah so that that's
obviously really interesting in itself
right that you've been in that company
for that long but obviously so you start
in Manchester and then you went down to
London right yep set the London team and
then you went from London to where you
are now right San Francisco and then
what you intend on doing is that I don't
know later this year are you gonna go
over to New York to New York yeah
probably in October tiesm
okay cool so I'm sure you've learned
fuckload the long way but I guess let's
just work what I was like to start with
initially as like so never knew about
recruitment obviously fell into it but
how were your sort of first ones because
it seems like you've pretty much hit the
ground running or you've done pretty
well quite early on so what
talk to me about your first four months
a bit so I kind of joined just at the
start roughly at the start of my
financial year and then went straight
into a pure BD role so 180 pure BD kind
of hit in the phone's 8200 cause of the
you know that's what you signed up for
yeah he'll be dealer I didn't really
know that there was another option to be
on the sailing I was kind of I hadn't
really researched it that way I just
needed a job yeah and I was kind of
interviewing the best the likes of s3
actually wanted a big recruitment job
like a big company you know how they
sell it yeah like the whole company come
down to London here and the top Billa
gets a car yeah that sounds good then I
really like to Finley gems and they
talked a lot about training throughout
the process and the onboarding the
support mmm and so I think as well it's
the people that you connect with yeah
it's so key isn't that state do you
interview for quite a few places then
when like maybe four or five recruitment
agencies for five offers no it didn't
actually finish ends with my first offer
I remember I phoned up my dad and and he
was obviously paying for me at that
point cuz I don't have any money
just come back from travel yeah I phoned
him up as I've got an offer but I've got
two final interviews surely I could do
that he said no no [ __ ] chance get
yourself in that job really who said you
take it and I took it about yeah so
certain the pure be dear old life so for
me spoken about quite a lot I decided on
the pure candidate he did some client
work initially but yeah that's how they
that's a model right to embedded me into
recruitment and then when it did the
bender and by that point I'd seen my
colleague DB Dean all that and when it
gets a rock a right he shouldn't I want
you to start building your own client
Bank and all this I'll [ __ ] my pants by
that point right but obviously naive to
the fact that you didn't has an option
and okay well this is recruitment I'm
doing it right yeah you just did it I I
I'm glad I did it the way that's why I
mean yeah
though I probably have less empathy I
didn't I didn't start doing candidates
till about maybe two or three years ago
so really two years in so what was you
talk to me about that then because that
may be quite a few people obviously I
think it's become more more popular now
in the UK to have that type of structure
well yeah yeah I think there's a lot of
conversation I've had their businesses
are looking to change that way but also
there's a lot of people stood in the 360
well right so yeah it was your job to do
what sign clients and get jobs on and
getting signed time yeah now is your job
done sign clients and I still manage the
account yes so I would still kind of
she'd build a relationship turn them to
paying customers but and then you do
also and obviously work with that
relationships about to maximize it yeah
so we might throw it you London expand
the account you still manage the
day-to-day so the way we do it is I
would still do the admin like you're
sending over the series of already
funded it's that count and would you
have any say on if that kind of date was
right yes yeah it goes out and might
that count that client is in my name
essentially so yeah I want to make sure
that it's yeah so I guess so that's all
we did in the first were all you did
until two three years right yeah for the
first two probably two years they told
me to London she was when I moved to
London in 20 let's just talk a bit about
that that first two year period make
because as I was telling you a lot of
people reach out and talk about want me
to talk about business development and
these things so firstly like how the
hell did you even approach that so did
you have data to attack did you have to
map out the market itself or light
because obviously by this point I guess
if you're going straight into it what
did you know about textiles at this
point I'm sure you didn't know yeah
that's what I mean so how do you not I
mean because that can be quiet
you know people can have a bit of fear
as to thinking they're gonna come across
stupid or unknowledgeable and those
things so how how did you approach those
first two years she just got on the
phones you know it for like we had
really good training in that they gave
you the questions to ask and it's never
okay you don't need to know about the
tech and you don't need to know
because why don't--why we're experts of
where the people move of in tech we're
not experts in tech yeah I was an expert
in tech I'd be a developer or I'd be
yeah so that's the best way to look at
yourself yeah and so it's it's like if I
knew all the answers those questions
they probably don't need my help
like right now I need to I need to ask
them questions yes we understand what
their business challenges and their
problems are yeah before you can just go
in and fix it yeah it was Finny Jensen
James May was my manager he sort of
hired me brought me untrained me up and
it was kind of trained I was trained to
ask questions around that was it didn't
make assumptions yeah I spent time as
much time as you could muting or on the
phone I mean and I'm a classic
salesperson who hates admin so I really
I would spend all my time on the phone
rather than sending the email suddenly I
just didn't like send it yeah just
lights obviously haven't looked good
that haven't your conversations okay so
let's break that down a bit then because
I know okay so did you sort of detach
the outcome of the calls do not I mean
because it's great however so what I
mean by that is it's like the intention
of all I'm doing is asking questions
right and what seems like you've done is
you're not thinking about the end result
that you need like a successful Court is
going to be demos on in terms or
whatever we can obviously put a bit of
pressure in yourself or yeah I think
unsuccessful so what were some of those
questions what what are the key things
that you tell your guys now that you
train up that you need to try and find
out on this phone call to make that a
successful business development call if
you have them for however long on the
phone yeah well you just you've got to
help them with their challenges right so
you got to find out what it is they're
looking for why they're hiring okay if
you don't understand and simon Sinek
talks a lot about yeah and start with
the wifey but if they don't know why and
then you kind of in a challenging spot
because they don't know why they're
hiring or so therefore they probably
don't know what they need
yeah so for you it's very much okay yeah
you are hiring but why that's that's
what you need to tap into exactly
exactly that and we want to understand
the foot that briefed fully if you get
sent a job spec which a lot of agencies
do and it's an HR job spec then you've
not got enough to really because that
allows me my next thing is like also I'm
sure you learn this
you gotta work the right jobs haven't
you you've got to get them at the right
jobs in and yeah that's a big part of
that isn't it
we have to qualify the client here
sometimes we do turn people away and not
every client is right for us and yeah I
suppose
okay cool and how what did it like in
terms of so did you just have a bank of
debt that you could call that light or
did you map things out and then just
have a bit of both so when you first
started it was kind of like you don't
why do you go for you training here's a
list of numbers for them really and it
was just like here's make 80 calls and I
would try and connect with them I'd have
a script I'd go through and I would try
and pass it to someone who was more
senior but really yeah it was quite
intense yeah yeah I wouldn't change it
there really let's talk about let's talk
a bit about of some sure it wasn't all
roses through that period you know I
mean that sure wasn't all positive so
like for me I'd i would definitely found
that really difficult and I know there
would be points where I'll be not
[ __ ] out like this is horrible
done a [ __ ] can crack on doing this
Ally what talking about some of your
load times made during that period
because surely you must have got a lot
of not backs and a lot of rejection for
example you didn't know any different
like yeah my job was to come on and
straightway I was told that if I made 80
calls I did I wanted to speak to 16
people and only one of them really
returning they were the expectation that
was very clearly set with me so only
expected to have one success real
successful call it would become a client
in in a day so yeah you get knocked back
all the time but I was kind of expecting
it really yeah I'll get that and that's
it I guess yes the expectations of that
you're like wow okay no this is just
part the process I'm no I'm gonna get
some Niners
yeah but I'm hunting for that that one
that one yes right that one yes and so
yeah whether that's the right way to do
it now no it's interesting
no I like I like that because it's light
I think let you know how it is you've
hired people right like it's that if you
then if you said so you only hard to do
it that way a lot of people probably
once that says there's effort in the
road but a lot of people would probably
tap out right I think I've quite a lot
we did that's what I mean so I mean so I
think that's why I was curious as to
what kept me going but I think it's very
simply there I did have a lot of success
I really in the sense that people were
placing my jobs so really either it was
because it's sometimes I had the good
consultants working it and I'd built up
relationships
yes internally there's a lot of when you
were the 180 mother you have to have the
relationships internally really because
if you don't have that relationship with
the person who's going to place your
role and you don't have the commitment
on your client then they're not gonna
okay I'll guess so there's a set a bit
of selling in town who's interested in
and so that that can you I guess from a
180 point of view you're not necessarily
in control of your own destiny a little
bit yeah but you do get to hone in on
that one skill yeah exactly
really become an expert of that PvP
which actually helps from the BD piece
when you move to the Canada side anyway
from a headhunter perspective you're
really like yeah because you just want
to be on the phone anyway yeah okay
that's true and okay so some good advice
for people that self that way is make
sure that you really cultivate the
relationships internally with the people
that are gonna be placing your jobs okay
that's pretty good advice so how how
would is it were like commission wise
and stuff then how does that work we do
split deals Lily yeah whoever who's the
client gets 50 percent and whoever gets
the candidate 50 percent okay we do have
some more sort of slightly different
models that sort of growing in now but
at the time at the time that's what it
was yeah we have some people where we
have like a client manager model where
someone of the BB guys brings on a
client passes it to a consultant who's
gonna then manage in my mind it's a 25
to literally just like just getting them
through the door again the terms yeah
okay and how did you do in those two
years billions why's that or that little
at me yeah so yeah one was I did 124
just over 124 pounds yeah and then yeah
it was good
yeah and then year two it was sort of
210 really and then yeah okay so let's
talk a little bit about that because I
think again a lot of people reach out
and say right well this year I'll build
150 180 can I take it to the 250
whatever so what did you love so I'm
sure there's so many learnings through
that first year like what did you start
doing morale
or less of to any key things that enable
you to take it to the to break the
tundra came up yeah that's a great
question really thought of it as
breaking the two hundred been the mark
yeah well if you think about you nearly
be said to what was at two through ten
Sinitta nearly doubled it right so yeah
do you know I mean so I think my first
year was like I started building in the
January now finally financially it ended
in October okay nine months yeah
so I think if I'd maybe had a fall
financially it might have been a bit
more based a little bit more so yeah but
I don't really know if it was anything
that broke the barrier search however I
became kind of more comfortable with the
role counsel more calm yeah you kind of
I don't think I changed anything of what
I was doing I was still making a lot of
calls amazing but that didn't change no
no doesn't change is the same I was just
I probably had a better qualified spec
and I've learned to pull off I bet ya
ask better questions yes these things
are probably waste time on clients that
yeah you know whatever that yeah okay
that make sense and how so at this point
just out of interest like how did you
structure your day
life like how did you literally make BD
calls from the moment you've got in yeah
doing the day I'd get through like what
we call that hot calls really anyone
just on the phone straight away then I
think what my day was like and we'd have
like a team meeting in the morning and
we'd kind of run through any new client
said what jobs on yeah and then it was
straight into calls again did you not
run out of people to speak to well I
would keep I would keep them up in the
market at the same time yeah so it
wasn't you as much fun to do that yeah
these were by that point after that the
first few weeks these were targeted
calls you know I was like looking at
LinkedIn yeah looking at leads that we
would get from other client candidates
yeah speaking to yeah and then I was
sort of researching I would spend that
time normally between like twelve and
two I would yeah nothing and then like
maybe for four to five something like
that yeah so if you again just got in
the pure tactics here because I think
because our buffing is valuable and so
like if I'm thinking about to how I
should it but like so let's say you've
got a client that you like right I've
heard some really good things about this
business I really want to work with them
right towards me a bit about that
process and you'd map out the
makers sushi makers you know how the how
the [ __ ] you tapping them up then
because how you gonna get their
information firstly let's just gonna
smash your switchboard switchboards yeah
or whether it's there's lots of plugins
these days yeah totally mate what the
[ __ ] so we use Ellucian yeah that's the
main one that we really so yeah that
that and that plug-in from what I've
heard is you can get access they're
movin on the right it's quite a lot the
time potentially like demo but it could
be so there's a lot in the US where
there might be someone with the same
name and so you end up thrown in like it
Dave Jones who's got the same name a
number yeah how does that work them so
does it pull it from the LinkedIn
profile I don't mental in that GDP are
compliant yeah of course they [ __ ]
are they okay and then just again I
think a lot of people get value at this
so you've done that you've got their
number what the [ __ ] you said on that
call the first times you know I mean
because you've got that number without
them knowing they don't know who you are
a lot the time right
like do people know who your deep no one
knows Nick guy at this point right know
that that's what I mean so like what you
say well how are you opening that cool
I'm sure it just comes natural to you
now
well I don't think I'd do it the same
way are we now to what I did talk about
how you do it now then because I'm sure
you've optimized it now more my role is
I guess through referral business okay
through people that I know and kind of
map in the market that way rather then
it was pho billionaire where now isn't
it well let's talk about pule code that
first cuz that last word a lot of people
were I just used to get on the phone and
just and just say like yeah I've heard
that my name is nick conforth in the
James yeah I heard that you're looking
to add to your sales team here what's
the most important thing you're looking
for
I really actually be straight about and
I know it's quiet sealer that's why I
hope they go hope they go into it then
if they'll obviously throw back obvious
normally surely do you spec up and the
days did you get jobs that way we did I
didn't at that point really but we as a
business we did but other people did
that yeah because that's where I've had
so much more success when you actually
have some it's a lot easier isn't it so
I'd say I started to do that I should I
definitely should have done it earlier
because that's the bet it's not about
success yeah I because I didn't work of
any candidates I oh yeah
I guess yeah from your point of view
calling someone and sort of really
knowing how to pitch this person could
be a bit difficult because that
communication in terms of got to be
really exactly but in hindsight what I
would do is I'd probably say look can I
spend ten minutes with you come to do it
yeah yeah yeah cuz and then it's the
other concern understanding how
marketable that kind of date is exotic
write down in ten minutes okay perfect
I'll now to spin this to my client and
okay mate so after those two years then
yeah why did you move down to London and
I wanted to it really a lot of my
friends had moved down from Manchester
to London yeah and I'm from Yorkshire
originally and all my friends that I'd
sort of grew up with they'd moved and
lived in London I just she moved to
London it like you made it you've made
his maiden the option I just kind of
wanted to what to experience as well
yeah sure yes I love London so I'm glad
I did it
okay so and how long was you in London
for it's just under two years around two
years two years yeah and your objective
was to build see there wasn't a London
team at that point it was no office
really I open the office and grow a team
she lit she went out there on your went
down on your obviously you would have
got supported that was Liberty was in an
office really I didn't I wasn't on the
own in sense I had friends that lived
here yeah yeah no but work was on the
work-wise and Manchester's not that far
away so yeah yeah nice to come on that
stuff you did on your own right I guess
do you go the support network which is
really important I'm sure you had the
support of everyone I've see the people
mfinney James and you've got the social
support all important but yeah we've got
a good brand as well yes so I guess
you're two years down the line obviously
you've had all this be the experience
and then so then now did you have to do
some sources so what was the object so
what was you trying to do more of was it
more like a client so you needed to try
and work with vol III wanted to learn
that side of the business because I was
gonna be true
I'd built a team in Manchester that was
pure BD so I really I was you build
people underneath you in Manchester I'd
built a team and could have been and I
do a few of our team members there so
I'd built that team but none of them
were consultants so I wanted to
my job is to bring up like consort BD
and delivery yeah so I wanted to do it
first I kind of knew I'd be able to do
it because I've seen the experience but
what the experience was the Furby was it
was it not so it was you and them having
any particular more focus on London
client anything like that or were you
just still doing the same what he did in
Manchester but now you had to build a
team and concerns and not busy even
though Manchester team a lot of the
clients that we work we've already in
London okay cause we were already we
already have the clients it was just to
be there on the ground but have it and
have a team on the ground now that was
the advantage to have a team on the
ground in London yeah and okay let's
talk a bit about that then so that your
rom must have been Tony did so I didn't
realize so you man and people did you
manage before you went down to London
really did you want to manage yeah I
think I did at the time like I try to
remember you kind of just have success
if you fall into it and yeah timing was
everything I I don't think I would have
asked for it at that point if I wasn't
offered to me yeah I think I would have
just carried on do it I was happy to do
my job I can I don't when the
opportunity came I thought let's see
what this is like let's see what you can
do okay so you gain that experience of
Horan 5 people which sauce is gonna help
youngness in London and let's talk a bit
about that then like so what was the
objective for the first 6 to 12 months
when he wasn't there so he was only
there for two years
yep and what time how big was a team by
the time he left it was really fun all
right so what what was the focus for you
then going down there then like what
what how do things change for you so the
difference is when I went down
originally there was no plan to leave
that really so we didn't have a time
scale of like it's 2 years you've got
two years yeah nobody was going to build
the London team built and we actually
went down first and tried to replicate
what I'd done originally so I'll really
it would be to build a BDD team yeah we
realized that without the support of the
consultants internally that internal
communication relationship ok what do
you do that we ripped it up and started
again and really made some consultants
ok so what what is your day now look
like
all of a sudden you've got worry about
getting people into your door you got
worried about sourcing you got worried
about getting clients yeah talk to me
about that mate
I don't think really what what you just
kind of have to do it yeah there's no
like you've clearly got that mentality
yeah I was just working longer hours
really I'm and there's no like I don't
think there's a secret no you've just
got to work out how how to what stuff is
really important that you need to do and
what stuff you you probably were doing
that you shouldn't be doing yes you you
worked out what what what activities to
focus on to get close to the outcomes
right so how do you structure it at this
point because that that must have been a
challenge for you to obviously you can
write long out longer hours obviously
but how did you make time to do
everything that you needed to at this
point I would get an early get all my
beauty calls done yeah and I would do
Beauty calls late as well really I'm
starting to build up a US market that's
what we have I really US clients as well
at this point so obviously I could do
those later in the evening really but it
was I did have a lot of support from
from the Manchester office as well so we
have internal trainers they were doing
training and stuff and help it helping
out from that perspective yeah but it
was just spending a lot more time with
the team really and just focusing on
yeah how quickly did you get some more
people went into the London office and
was a quite quick call high three like
right away I think I really so you
initially had some people to work on and
how then yeah I don't use I'd already
come down to do some like interviews and
stuff before I made the move and so we
had at least one which I think we I
think we have three started by November
and I moved in the October alright okay
so yes she had a couple of people
already sort of in the pipe in the back
we're going to start him okay that's
good okay cool and then how so did this
affect your billions like I haven't to
do all this different stuff now in like
q2 so I q1 is October to December
q2 yeah did that first pew two hours in
that I think I did like maybe a third of
what I would not was doing a previous q2
but then I made it back up in yeah and
is that that's because you there's just
so much [ __ ] going on yeah I think it
was just a new chat a new challenge so
like I said trying to work out what the
day-to-day would look like yeah
and some of it you do buy because for me
I have to do a lot of it by trial and
error we'd never yeah I London office
before and I certainly haven't done
consultancy I bet yeah have you so is
this always been the Nick guy animate
just to like learn fail optimize do
things better do you not I mean like
where's this come from is other night
just out of interest because it seems
like this stubbornly phase you but like
a lot that's obviously a great
achievement right but I think the fact
that you were approaching it that way is
how you should approach it yeah it's
very easy for me to look back on it and
talk like whether I was like that at the
time right now it's very easy to look
back and reflect on it and say oh yeah
I've made this mistake I didn't at the
time maybe I didn't think I was making
the mistake and yeah you had the
complete inner ambition to make it
[ __ ] one yeah but I very money I was
very money driven was yeah so yes I
wanted to make a lot most still do want
to like making more money and why should
I make a lot money I don't know really
that's a good point just to be able to
afford things in the future
yeah invest it and and do things I like
to travel actually yeah Vinnie Jones
allowed me to do a bit of that let's do
my own trouble yeah sure no no it's
interesting because I think I've also
quite a few times now like if you're
interviewing a consult like oh yeah I
want to get in recruitment cuz I want
I'm motivated by money yeah is that
enough for you yep I mean I do the same
as you yeah I'm like what why why do you
want money you don't even know you're
[Laughter]
okay yeah because it's like if the thing
is if you do have a bit more attached to
it then it's gonna have to get through
those [ __ ] time yeah and isn't that
you know I just always liked it so like
from a young age from I think I started
work from age of 13 like waning wrothian
washing dishes in a pub because I knew I
wanted money to be able to do things
yeah it gives you options right exactly
okay so how so then how did you billions
wise before you went to San Fran and
we'll talk a bit about how that came
about like what does that look like then
did it continue to increase or no I
think I did so the 210 in my second year
2:16 in my third one I think it was and
then the fourth one was like when I kind
of made the move halfway through my
financial year yeah to to yet Thomas and
then that became like in pounds it was
about three three three I think okay all
right so and a bit around the you
building the team in London so the
consultants that you took on was it
still there so you did all the bidding
and they did a source sent was that all
they do 316 we did BD so I'm sorry say
yeah I was training Beauty people tried
to replicate what we've done in
Manchester yeah realize that actually
the reason it worked in Manchester was
because we had a nation and then we
decided these guys had done some Biddy
training so they became more two more
delivery focus and they were previously
but they could still do better training
yeah they became I guess you could say
360 but there was a weight heavy waiting
on delivery really okay and what did you
what did you see so those people that
worked under you mate what what are some
of the common things that you saw in
these people that enable them to have
the success that they wanted or some of
the common things that you've seen that
have prevented people having success and
let's talk a bit about that because I'm
sure you've learnt a bit along because
you just continue to build teams and see
different people and those things
definitely yeah I think I think what I
would say is is having one person to
kind of open the office isn't
necessarily the best way to do it I
think that most people were because we
were doing a grad model they they learn
through seeing other people do it
hearing it on the phone only hard grads
we did so because we'd worked well in
Manchester yeah yeah which I again and
we had some people who perhaps more
experienced but I think it would have
been nicer to have some of our more
senior consultants go down as well where
you can learn and or they could spend
time with them yeah because that's how I
learned I kind of sat next to some of
the senior people went over which kind
of sponge just listen to what they were
doing well I'm working my own way of
doing it and then trying to yeah so some
of these non experience people then like
what are some of the things that because
a lot of people quit recruitment in the
first
you know people listen to this maybe
early on in their career or later on in
their career like what are some of the
things that you've seen there yeah I
mean I always like people that had a job
when they were university or don't
necessarily need to have gone to
university have worked from young age to
showed that's all about
outside I guess you'd call it hustle
well yeah they've kind of gone out to
try and get it on their own
yeah those people have always been the
more successful people merely yeah why
do you think that is done because
they're content they have a bit more bit
more grit to them yeah so I think that I
like people that have done like multiple
things that they've played sport they've
had a job and they were doing some form
of Education they could show that they
can manage their time well to be able to
things and if they've done them all at
high level you've you've got that aspect
of they've been able to overachieve in
in multiple areas yeah and I think
that's important in recruitment because
you do juggle a lot yeah totally okay so
and then so so how much American
business were you doing before we went
to America did you have a few American
clients I did have quite a few I can
tell you the percentage did that just
happen naturally then like did a lot of
your UK clients have American arms to
their business I actually started when I
was in Manchester there was a consultant
that worked at the time and either
started we should stay late on it we'd
start late on a Friday and we'd stay
late on a Friday [ __ ] it and we'd we'd
worked it mate we'd work to like 8
o'clock really straight to the town off
that straight - yeah straight to the pub
afterwards and you know we'd have a beer
a desk or whatever yeah that's kind of
how it started I can't really remember
if these recognize an opportunity and I
think someone said no I'm not looking
here but I'm looking in the in New York
or wherever it was let's get some
clients give it a go and really use
something work out that the fees are
twice as much yeah it's just as easy so
mate let's talk a bit about this because
I think I have weekly conversations now
with recruitment businesses that are
opening and opening American offices
yeah so let's talk a bit about what
you've learned through this process of
doing more American business going out
to America yep I'm sure you've learned a
lot there what do you know I mean to lie
it firstly
continue to make mistake
really but I guess what so did you just
approach it I'm sure you would have
discipline straight away so you Matt's
out who these people were funding city
makers and you're calling them to send
high money's Nick guy naturally we are
we hope we have a lot of because what we
do in sales a lot of people do their
first man on the ground or first woman
on the ground in the in the UK and so we
do quite senior sales person yeah so we
just then with those clients but they
already have a us sort of present so we
just learned back and expand back into
those but ok see let so you leverage
your existing relationship yep
and start some new ones yeah okay but
that make sense so yeah
what would you advise be them people
that want to get more American
businesses start from scratch it's it's
easier to to do to go out there if
you've already got a client base so I
would say start while you're in the UK
good yeah we have a team still that
purely folks they called the US team and
they're based in Manchester and they
focus on the US market bit from real
Korean and I've recognized an
opportunity there as you said bigger
fees because term assume higher and and
yet turns are higher I say when I say
just as easy I don't mean recruitments
easy pledged it's the same difficulty
level is doing yeah exactly but the
rules are higher right exactly because
it margin those things so yes I a farmer
recruiter right now and in my market
there is a real opportunity to go over
to America or to do more American
business because of the sector I'm in
what's your advice make it free what
you've never take my but what I need to
get clients so how am I gonna do that
what about what should I do I think for
me there's no difference to do it out
here you want to speak to some
candidates and get some leads off them
yeah you want to map out who you want to
speak to and the businesses you want to
work with yeah and if you know your
industry stick with your knees yeah and
go and speak okay fine but it is easier
if you know people so if you've got
clients you go to Malaysia to leverage
those yes that's kind all of a sudden
you can start a called lives I've been
working with your UK team that for this
what for this man period yeah this is
why I wanted to especially because we
work with a lot of startup so the
businesses are naturally small yeah if
you're working with huge corporations I
don't like someone like Deloitte yeah
sure they have direct yeah so leveraging
existing relationships that's good
advice
and how received was it that this
American decision-maker was on the final
of a southern system guy Manchester
later bought this do you not I mean like
how does that receive cuz I'm sure some
people will make assumptions they're
like how how is that gonna be received
you know I mean he didn't be positive or
mixed review some people like yeah well
you can't come and meet the candidates
because you're in Manchester yeah and
and so you come across that but most of
them you're hiring is one of their
number one yeah if you can solve the
problem yeah they kind of open to it but
you've got to be able to solve the
convince them that you can solve them
yeah totally so yeah I'll get that so
how did you how do you how do you deal
with that objection then like okay well
you're in the UK so how how you gonna
judge you can't it just really yeah yeah
but so you would just say give me a
chance
yeah sure and did you so did you do all
see quite a bit of American business
before you went home view as you said
yeah you you I'll say more than like 25
percent of life Billings were coming
from America winning know exactly but it
was definitely modern yeah that's okay
so why did you want to go to San Fran
mate yeah New York I did it first but I
had more clients in San Francisco my
brother was out in San Francisco as well
so I had family there oh really
yeah at the time he's not anymore but at
the time he was and culturally it's
someone Cisco seems a little bit closer
to Manchester and what New York seems
I've not lived there so I don't know but
it seems a lot kind of faster for us
like hustle and bustle New York that you
hear about right yeah yeah swallow you
and spit you out yeah exactly so okay
so again the person you are did you stop
for a challenge yeah yeah went for it
yeah thing anything else no just who did
you go over with I went on my own on
your own yeah and then use all of a
sudden an office on your own in San Fran
no so we hired so we I went out for like
a month in November 17 I think it was
and we'd hire three people to start then
yeah and the mistake we made I guess is
we thought that we get the visa so that
back out in January so I'd go home for
December
back agenda but my visa actually got
delayed because the couple of reasons
mr. Trump hmm kind of slowed down things
and the embassy moved which meant I
didn't actually get my visa until June
really so we had three grads that had
six like well that's six months just on
the seven months really on their own oh
[ __ ]
really yeah if you manage him from the
UK and I was managing from the Yukon
yeah that in hindsight what I would do
is I would have brought more of my
colleagues out with me
superb you've already got relations yeah
exactly so that well you can build more
a better culture when you've got a few
people that know the business and I'd
have liked to be on the ground with them
for the start so we made that mistake
but we kind of rolled with the punches
and yeah and try to try to make it work
- when did you get that June June okay
and then how long you been there now
okay that year that mate ups and downs
we've really yeah we've kind of had a
the revenue that's been like real good
yeah we just seem to be good are us
revenue based so just continue to grow
grow yeah what we've kind of learned is
that it's very expensive to hire in San
Francisco okay anyway let for what for
what type of skill set like lychee a
great experience really no no it's more
it's more expensive eggs exactly and a
lot of them don't quite know what not
that they don't know what they haven't
experienced obviously they haven't
experienced agency recruitment or the
differences internal and agency and it's
very easy for them well they're just
coming to test out agency and it's an
expensive way to test yeah no burrows
and then they decide that it's not for
them they go in turn a lot to go and try
a different job and so in you said that
they're not the knick guys of eight
equals a day [ __ ] smash it out no
exact room is that anymore no no you
don't need to do that to be successful
in this job and that's something you've
learnt right the one it's expensive to
hire someone that might be actually
testing as a career or whatever but then
also I guess what you said is may not
have them I don't know the approach or
skill set to yeah how how you'd like it
or how you
need a bit more from them basically I
think I hired too quickly as really so I
think because we went from like when
when I got out there from there were
three so then myself was four to nine in
about two months three lips and that
meant that I was obviously kind of
pulled in but I was still bringing on
clients still trying to make revenue as
well as training speaking out for now
and I'd probably should have spent more
time focusing on the team on a smaller
group the people that you already had
yeah rather than rather than trying to
hire to make numbers because actually
does really matter how many people you
have yeah exactly you have good people
yeah so then okay mate now that's really
interested in what some would have been
that I guess that's just sort of the
nuances of people that worked in growing
up in America right so what are some
things that you've picked up on around
that then that you now look out for or
what are the some of the differences I
think I'm still learning that I don't
think there's an answer to that yet that
I've really worked out but there are
some some differences in the work-life
balance is very different in a more
they're in California particularly
people will like come in in other
offices they come in at 9:00 and they
leave it 3:30 really which is very
different to what I'm used to in
recruitment here where it's like yeah
you're in a and you leave at 6:00
minimum sort of thing yeah it's probably
less like that these yeah I'm not I mean
recently but but it's yeah so it's a bit
more relaxed than a bit it's a bit more
it's just like a yeah yeah I I don't
think that the challenges of hiring or
any different I experienced the same
challenges with people in the yeah as I
guess did you have to love position the
opportunity differently it you know I
mean like that you have to talk about in
a different way kind of the differences
between agency and internal I had to
talk about a lot because in that like
corporate they call it is that internal
or not I've not heard it called that
they're my really I've not heard it
called like corporate recruits it live
seen that quite a lot names in this I
have seen that I think that's from a job
to a perspective them yeah okay so talk
to me about some of the the sort of
experiences that you found from now work
in America live in America and I'll see
some assuming quite a lot of your
business do whatever you care clients
I have a couple of you have put on him
now Americans so what have you learned
through that process mate like how are
you so I've shown though there's no
difference in terms of the tactics now
you're approaching it but like why is it
do you think that they wouldn't pay more
fees what do you not mean like what I
mean I live I've had a few conversations
around it but what's your perspective as
to why people willing to do that yes
it's not always the case that people are
willing to prepare higher margins I
think as a general rule our margins are
probably higher but the salaries are
higher so summer Cisco as I mentioned
it's more expensive therefore when you
charge a percentage relative isn't it
naturally it goes up so it's and if you
just focused in the state of San Fran
all of you but try to we don't across
the whole u.s. really yeah okay because
we'll get a lot of clients where they'll
build a sales team and it's like we want
one person in the Pacific Northwest one
one in the Bay Area one in Orkin and so
you kind of help them all but surely
you've got a focus there because it's so
big yes I mean we focus on on the sales
vertical rather yeah so anything that's
related to the sales yeah yeah okay so I
guess how are these what what's the
difference in terms of the perception of
recruitment over there then do you think
that you've picked up on because in the
UK doesn't have a great name whatsoever
so do you not I mean what yeah I think
people really a lot of people want to
get into recruitment like and what
they've heard was if it's not like I say
it they don't see it as a sales role
very often I mean I think it's more
about like you know we want to help
people with their career yeah and that
when so we're kind of educating them but
the agency side of it is actually a lot
although you do do Halpin parts a
tenement sales role you know yeah yeah
and you're gonna make things happen and
run your own little desk in your own
business yeah but I think there is a
perception that you're helping in your
career advisor career coach asking are
definitely feel a lot of question here
what doesn't they say okay cool
so slight a slight segue because I know
we focused on sort of you building teams
and your experience too through that I
see a lot of you online mate obviously
something I'm really passionate about
and personal brand in these things I'll
talk about
a lot in here but how's that I mean I
feel like you're pretty consistent you
sort of understand and how you wanna be
perceived you're communicating well like
what how has that helped you as a
recruit you know I mean cuz I think
that's a big part of how it's changing
yeah it has it has helped it has in more
way in in the sense that there have been
times and it's only happened so I've
been trying to post and like at least
once a day sort of thing when I'm in
work try and do at least a post a day
I've been doing that probably since I
moved out there I try to some ups and
downs yeah honestly I think you've been
pretty consistent and you done all that
you don't have to post every day but
you've been pretty consistent and I
tried to keep that consistency and now
sometimes when I speak to canvas like
I've seen your posts people have said
that to me it's like oh I know it so
you're the guy that post this and yeah
yeah yeah I would say that how is it how
does that help of Solana how it helps me
but how does it how does it help to use
it because people are still trying to
understand how are you trying to post
every couple of days is gonna benefit my
billings or have you been that benefit
me as a recruited you know I mean so
it's helped you because how I would say
that what from one perspective it's a
warmer call it the Apple have already
seen time it's a woman definitely great
in there you've got some credibility and
they see was an expert yeah what should
my people want that there's there's a
lot of noise and recruitments a lot of
noise in probably every industry at the
moment so if you can position yourself
as an expert who adds a real value
throughout the process yeah then people
more like to once away with you so it's
yeah I couldn't agree more so III that's
why I experienced in recruitment was our
team I saw a video that and then yes
that perception piece in there's a lot
of cases guy one knows what he's doing -
he should definitely hope you had to
help me and also you got a lot of
competition my engagement as well you
having conversations with people that
you might necessarily be speaking to and
and you've you kind of creating a
pipeline of like a talent pool or talent
man yeah exactly that you can tap into
in the future so it's thinking that long
term game rather than the short I'll
Italia oh it's not gonna benefit me now
but there's people I've probably spoken
to online and that have regular
conversations because they post on my
and calm
that's here that maybe in a year's time
I can help them find a job
exactly you're paying it forward right
yeah that's what it's about and I think
hiring managers in that's the right
mindset isn't it it's like yeah but in
recruitment desk it's the long-term game
where you see the rural success right
and I've seen successes from others that
do it well in like this so people that
focus on building the sales as a few
like people that I've seen do it really
well
I also like that idea and I was robbed
way Neil market I wouldn't say they're
not recruiters but they're they might be
consultants that helps it the similar
sort of yeah it's to what we do yeah and
they try a position themselves as
experts and yeah you've learnt from that
yeah okay now that makes sense
how how do you know you've been in
recruiting for quite a while now I know
see you you're probably something that
it's super focused and they're cracks on
but like how did you see there I'll see
you moving to New York soon this is
exciting
yep so I how how do you see recruitment
changing over the next couple of years
that's a good question I think maybe a
couple of years I'm not sure with a bit
of change that that mean I think they'll
be less of an office focus really I
think I see a lot and hear a lot of
people talking about work-life balance
yeah the flexibility to work from home
9:00 till 3:30 hours yeah but it's it's
at flexibility at the time you would
spend commuting yeah why you need to do
that and I think there's a lot of people
that are posting about that at the
moment I think I think you've got I
think you've got to know what works for
you as well there isn't that life for me
I I would find it really difficult
sitting at home in my underpants like
yeah I need to be run humans I know that
whereas do you not I mean like I think
you've gotta have some self-awareness oh
this is important do not mean you've got
some self-awareness as to what what
works for me and what's gonna enable me
to have you have the best success but I
think it's gonna be the disgust of so
much noise in the market and you'll
probably of the starts better than I do
about how many agencies are kind of
coming up you've got a position yourself
as an expert you know and add value yeah
totally and it's now what would I guess
we would have traditionally probably
added throughout the process you know
this is this is a feature or a benefit
of what we do
you've now got to do before the
so even start early and I think just to
add on what you're talking about there I
think everything that you post and all
these things it doesn't replace you
didn't want the fight you're great at
which no good Malaysia it just it just
helps it it should you know I mean so
it's it's about combining the two that
that's it's never for me it's not gonna
replace the proactive calling having the
conversations but as you said it's so
LinkedIn's now like you're online it's
your reputation exactly run so people
would people will check you out there
for credibility as if you've pitched
them on the phone and they're like yeah
its credibility to I think okay so let
conscious of time quickly before we
finish what I always like to ask and I
think I know I've sort of tried to ask
you about it already but do you do
anything yourself to invent like
personally and your own development like
mindset of stuff because look Manchester
to London
yup to San Fran it's now New York that's
that's some real [ __ ] mate
so no I mean like I wouldn't I know
maybe it just comes natural to you but
have you do make time to invest in
yourself and do you not I mean yeah I
think I know what you talk about so I
guess I do from a sense I list or
podcasts mm-hm I try to consume as much
content as I can from any point of view
yeah I think we both I think you do too
about us thought Gary Vee yeah I really
kind of bath when I listen to his
podcast I started getting into more of
them and kind of listen to new other
people now yeah so you do make time to
invest in yourself yeah because I think
that all of that like you're gonna
obviously you'll learn it through the
ways you're gone but you're gonna have
to have some real solid I don't know
what you'd call it habits tactics that
you can lean on to help you [ __ ] get
through those times right having a
mentor is have you had an aha moment so
I have to yeah
really yeah outside of fini James one is
now working
Andrew McCaskill oh okay was we'd only
done a couple of sessions and then he
ended up joining Finney James but Wow
so he's still obviously we were closer
to Gavin up how did you get a mentor
there'll be a lot of people listening
I'd put people in touch I just went
asked so the really the other
mental that have is actually a British
guy in San Francisco and I just went and
asked him and said look you've been
successful and you've kind of gone
through he's outside of recruitment
industry
yeah but he's set up an office in San
Francisco yeah I said I think I could
learn a lot from an outsider's
perspective and really she just
positioned it from like I feel like like
did you sort position anyway I'd like
what's in it fit other night I think
it's of I've never been asked to be a
mentor but I were from what I've heard
from the food but it's a flattering
thing to be yeah yeah totally yeah yeah
so I think she'll issues reached out
what LinkedIn or just funded I just
obviously yeah yeah how did you position
on them cuz again trust me there'll be a
lot of people listen and they're like
know what that I think I'd really
benefit from a new mentor say you know
identify some people link LinkedIn have
just done one in the US but they've sent
out an email where you can be a mentor
and I've been really into give back as
well so I'm I'm going to in the yes
that's interesting is it they've run an
event on like that July or something way
I've signed up and said that I will go
for whatever the world and then it's to
mentor like gradual yeah and how has
that helped you I would say it's just
sometimes it's good to just talk about
things yeah it's a bouncy ideas
particularly when for me when I was over
eight I was behind on a time zone from
from our headquarters if business
challenges come up it's just good to
bounce it that this is what I'm thinking
am I going crazy yeah sure am i
overthinking this or whatever it is and
having an outsider's perspective someone
who's not in the industry but has been
building as valuable was real value
books who think of things I wouldn't
yeah that's really interesting actually
because I think I think more recruiters
could benefit from that convey that
again someone who maybe hasn't watched
some equipment whatever get their
perspective as to how they could build
their business or their recruitment desk
or whatever from ups it's the same right
when you join the business you sit next
to that you always try to sit next to
the top biller yeah not everyone would
do that and maybe naturally you did that
mate yeah we're a small office in my
chest really so it was kind of sat with
everyone yeah fair enough
what before we finish that mate
obviously excited about New York yep but
what what else is going on
your world mate that you were excited
about what scandal really New York was a
plant for New York then lightly gone
over in Iran law but I'm not no Justine
from our San Francisco offices yeah yeah
two of us yeah I know just gonna smash
ups from day one basically yeah we're
gonna I think we're gonna learn from the
mistakes that we've made and rather than
so if it's expensive to hire grads out
there um we're gonna have more
experienced people I and focus on little
talent pools with rather than build like
a big headquartered in New York on
Manhattan Island but it's really really
expensive I think having two or three
people that are on the ground there two
or three people in Boston two or three
little pockets little little pockets of
people that can compete there but
perhaps more senior yeah what's up
what's the next day that you can
immunity there mate next day oh really
I could see myself back have you have
you been now in the holiday and four or
five times to New York how would you
describe it anchors and I had to go on
here a couple of weeks ago who's from
New York and worked in New York as a
recruiter and then I live with a guy
who's a recruiter who went to New York
and it just absolutely choose him up and
spat him out like literally I was in a
bad bad bad boy I was like what the [ __ ]
of are done is so light no but I let you
know yourself so yeah been there four
five times people consider over to New
York Club what should they be thinking
about like whatever y'all thought about
on what you expected so it's because
it's not to October from where you where
you're gonna live I think it's good to
have an idea of where you want to live
but you can't really pick and be super
aggressive when you get there so yeah I
guess all I'm thinking of is that I
really enjoyed my time in London yeah I
moved to San Francisco I've enjoyed it I
prefer the bigger city yeah it's over
buzz yeah exactly and all my visits to
New York I've really enjoyed it yeah so
I'm gonna go see what it's like yeah
yeah I like it
last question mate I always like to ask
it if you could communicate to every
single recruiter out there it can be a
phrase sentence or word whatever they
listen they take your advice what would
you say I would say I think you've got
to keep low
and developing like don't have become
complacent I think it's very easy like
when you're in a small business as well
that if you've reached the the kind of
top level you kind of that's you've set
that bar I would never say there's a bar
there were people and I've learned once
we saw that I sort of hit the top level
of Finley James but that was actually
only a drop in the ocean compared to
what some people out there are doing
yeah and I think you've just got to
always have that growth mindset yeah and
and just keep developing keep learning
and positioning yourself with people who
who know what they're doing like it man
it's been a pleasure mate my speech said